,
FORMER NAVY SEAL WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM JOIN US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
BEFORE I ASK YOU WHAT WE SHOULD
DO, I CAN'T RESIST ASKING YOU
THAT JUST JUST HUNTER BIDEN BUT
UNDER PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION,
THEY FELT THE NEED TO USE
AMERICAN POWER FOR SOME KIND OF
SOCIAL EXPERIMENT TO REARRANGE
THE TRADITIONAL SOCIETY IN
AFGHANISTAN, HOW IS THAT IN OUR
NATURAL INTEREST AND WHY WOULD
WE DO THAT?
>> IT'S THE SAME COLLECTION IN
WASHINGTON THAT HAS FAILED FOR
THAT ENTIRE 20 YEARS.
THEY TOOK WHAT WAS A BRILLIANT
VICTORY BY SPECIAL OPERATIONS ON
THE CIA AND THE FIRST SIX MONTHS
AFTER 9/11 AND TURNED IT INTO A
MASSIVE FAIL NATION-BUILDING
EXERCISE AND IT'S LARGELY BEEN
LIKE A "STAR TREK" COSPLAY
CONVENTION WHERE THEY JUST SIT
AND TALK TO EACH OTHER AND
DELUDE THEMSELVES INTO THINKING
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND
IT'S BEEN THE SAME NONSENSE AND
THEY REFUSED TO THINK ABOUT ANY
OTHER WAYS TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND AFGHANISTAN WAS NEVER REALLY
A COUNTRY AND THEY IGNORED THAT
AND TRIED TO MAKE THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT NIRVANA IGNORING ANY
KIND OF CENTRAL OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BASED ON THEIR
SOCIAL EXPERIMENT IN THE U.S.
MILITARY REPLICATED ITSELF.
THEY'RE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
MILITARY IN THE WORLD,
REPLICATED ITSELF WITH A LOT OF
EXPENSIVE CAPABILITIES AND WE
HAVE BEEN BEATEN BY WEAPONS
DESIGNED COVERED BY LARGELY
ILLITERATE GOAT HERDERS.
IF THERE IS ANY SHAME IN
WASHINGTON, THERE SHOULD BE A
LOT OF PEOPLE RESIGNING AND IF
NOT, THEY SHOULD BE FIRED.
>> BUT THEY'RE GOING TO GET AWAY
WITH IT.
I'M SORRY TO SAY THIS.
IT MUST FRUSTRATE YOU MORE THAN
ANYONE BECAUSE YOU SPENT YOUR
LIFE THERE BUT THEY ARE GOING TO
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THE PEOPLE THAT DID THIS WE MADE
THESE DECISIONS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT COUNTRY.
>> THE REALLY DISGUSTING THING
IS THE PEOPLE THAT MADE THOSE
DECISIONS IN THE COMFORT OF
THEIR OFFICES DON'T HAVE TO LIVE
WITH A LOST LIMBS, LIVES,
MARRIAGES, THE REAL DAMAGE AND
ON TOP OF THAT JUST TODAY WHAT
USED TO BE THE U.S.'S BIGGEST
BASE, ALL THE AL QAEDA AND ISIS
PRISONERS WERE RELEASED SO THE
ONES THAT WERE RELEASED BROUGHT
TO AFGHANISTAN ARE NOW FREE AND
OPEN ON THE RANGE AGAIN.
UNLEASHING TERROR.
AND WE WILL LIVE WITH THESE
CONSEQUENCES FOR YEARS TO COME.
WHEN THE U.S. TOTALLY FAILED IN
VIETNAM, THEY WERE 30 MILLION
PEOPLE DYING HAS A SECONDARY
EFFECT OF THAT.
TRUST ME, THIS PROBLEM WILL
SPREAD TO THE REGION, THE
TALIBAN NEVER DISAVOWED
AL QAEDA, THE COSPLAY DIPLOMACY
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN THE
UNITED STATES THINKING THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE A DEAL WITH THE
TALIBAN WHETHER IT'S A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THE SAME
KNUCKLEHEADS GETTING REALLY BAD
ADVICE AT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
LEVEL HAVE GOTTEN AWAY WITH THE
SAME FAILED APPROACH.
>> Tucker: IF I TAKE OVER MY
CRANE AND KILL PEOPLE, I DON'T
GET A PROMOTION AND A BIGGER
CRANE.
WHY IS IT THAT ONLY WHO HAS A
HAND IN EVERY BAD DECISION IN
THIS COUNTRY HAS MADE IN THE
PAST 20 YEARS HAS POWER AGAIN,
HOW CAN THIS HAPPEN?
>> WE HAVE GONE THROUGH 18
GENERALS IN CHARGE OF
AFGHANISTAN.
NONE OF THEM RESIGNED IN DISGUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE RESTRAINED
FROM NOT FIGHTING OR FROM
CARRYING OUT THE OPERATIONS THEY
WAY THEY WANTED SO THEY HAVE NO
EXCUSE.
ONE WAS FIRED FOR EMBARRASSING
OBAMA BUT NONE HAVE BEEN FIRED
FOR FAILING TO DELIVER VICTORY.
THE TAXPAYERS HAVE DONE THEIR
PART, LORD KNOWS WE SPENT A LOT
OF MONEY, THEY HAVE FOUGHT WELL
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE FAILED
LEADERSHIP AND ALLOWED LAWYERS
TO BECOME WITH THE POLITICAL
OFFICERS WERE FIGHTING WITH HALF
MEASURES, IT MAKES IT ALL THE
WASTE SO I AM TRULY SAD FOR THE
VETERANS THAT SEE THIS GO.
WE HAVE LOST 60,000 VETERANS TO
SUICIDE IN THE GLOBAL WAR ON
TERROR, MORE THAN WE LOST IN
VIETNAM FROM DESPAIR FROM SEEING
IT DONE POORLY.
DIVIDED BY SACRIFICE MYSELF, WHY
DO I HANG IT OUT THERE WITH MY
BUDDIES EVERY DAY WITH
HALF-BAKED POLITICIANS IN
WASHINGTON.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Tucker: IT WAS EVEN SADDER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE BUT